erica jane isn't here for the chatter
about her latest look
oh come on the real housewives of
beverly hills star traded her usual
glammed up appearance
for a dress down ensemble while pumping
gas in los angeles on monday
and the whole thing had people talking
amid her ongoing
legal woes i'm a princess
pretty mess singer who wore a green
billionaire boys club t-shirt
black leggings and white sneakers for
the outing took to social media to clap
back at the haters and
shout out those coming to her defense
why not
how about that when one fan tweeted
quote y'all don't know
about erica cause this has always been
her when she's just hanging with her
friends
but go off i guess erica retweeted the
sentiment
writing exactly and when another fan
shared
this gif writing my thoughts every time
i pump gas
the performer responded quote seriously
though
hey listen i already said what i had to
say everyone else can pick up where i
left off
then later that night erica dropped the
mic tweeting quote
goodnight twitter please be in full glam
when pumping gas
apparently it's a big deal erica's
clapbacks come amid her and her
estranged husband
tom gerardi's legal troubles before she
logged off she added a couple more
comments
writing when did everyone on twitter
become a expert on others personal lives
do you actually believe this and later
quote
everyone is so pressed but i did find
out the name of one of the snakes
feeding bad info no surprise really this
person
always struck me as weak
a lawsuit was filed against the pair in
december on behalf of several families
who lost
loved ones in the lion air flight 610
crash
which occurred in october 2018. tom
allegedly embezzled
settlement money that was supposed to go
to the family members of the victims
tom and erica are accused of using that
money to fund their own lavish
lifestyles
and allegedly pay off loans to keep
tom's law firm afloat
tom is a lawyer that has a you know he
has his own firm he has his own clients
and so that is his first
responsibility erica announced her split
from tom in november
a month before he was forced into
involuntary bankruptcy
and on tuesday a motion filed by the
bankruptcy trustee investigating tom's
assets
claimed that erica's businesses have
been given over 20 million dollars in
loans from tom's law firm over the span
of multiple years
in the upcoming episodes of the real
housewives fans will get a little more
insight into their split
let's discuss the elephant in the room i
did not see it ending this way
i was going to hold that man's hand till
he died i told him i loved him
and he said thanks tom he got served the
next morning
wow and earlier this month an abc news
doc dropped on hulu titled the housewife
and the hustler
i think the biggest question that
everybody has is did she know
the doc dives into the details
surrounding tom's alleged embezzlement
tom is being accused by his own clients
people that hired him that trusted him
from stealing money
that's the worst thing a lawyer can do
he had private jets he had a pasadena
mansion
he was spending 40 000 a month on erika
in her glam squad
they were just blowing money left and
right tons of money
the special also addresses one of the
latest developments which came in
february
when tom was placed under a temporary
conservatorship
in march a psychiatrist told courts tom
suffers from alzheimer's disease
and that he is unable to care for his
own personal or financial
matters viewers were quick to weigh in
on the dock some fans came to erica's
defense while
others just seemed to be basking in the
drama anything can happen
and back in may etie spoke to erica's
co-star garcelle bouvet
who shared her own two cents on it all
her life
changed drastically in a matter of you
know days i can relate to that when i
got my divorce it was public
is you know it's hard to live something
so personal
so publicly and being on a reality show
just
amplifies it that much more so i
definitely feel for her
and most but i feel for the victims
it was absolutely true then
my heart goes out to the victims and no
one else